and we're all kind of like i already
hate this
i haven't you're seeing a black screen
i'm seeing a black screen with a title
see now things are set up so that they
can't really see that i know isn't it
great but i can always see it and i'm
already angry
guys get ready to be angry
well you ruined it for me now uh who has
better legs mike
brendan shaw versus versus an nfl player
stacy keebler
she's still hot she's still hot
nick farnett that's him dude yep that's
him there he is
there he is who's better looking you got
to see him in person
cat i like i also like that whole
calling people cats who
who are you stone cold steve austin
you're a [ __ ] jazz singer enough
nope you got to see him in person at the
end of the day
this kid is no joke i don't know if his
legs are bigger than possible
dude listen hey hold on i'm raining
hey is it raining because that's a fat
tear drop bye bye listen
oh you're gonna make it hard on us today
hell brendan
i just want it on record i don't even
hate them i hate you hey mike
i hate you you have some needle and
thread
cause i'm so ripped i
hate you huh huh
hey mike mike
they can't hear you better turn the
gains up
i'm i'm rising crying i'm actually
really angry rising
[ __ ] grind very angry right now
rising grind let's check it out listen
to me
i i'm sorry i'm not that big a fan of
your legs i said it out loud
i'm sorry dude oh they're doing the
thing again
yeah it's funny oh take it easy
they're all right papa i've seen your
quack quack quads
papa listening like oh you got tiny
underwear dude
and your dick is pointing your dick
looks disappointing cover your dick on
the camera
that's a disappointing guys
men doing men things
men doing guy thing so
[ __ ] cringe men doing
guys things
this is uncomfortable
what what like
i'm speechless i'm [ __ ] speechless
why do people watch these guys like they
gotta you gotta be what are you gonna
trick off to exactly that's but that was
my point what are you going to jerk off
to
you have to be a gay guy to watch these
two
they're all right papa they're all right
look
dude
i don't know it's like something that he
heard and now he's going to repeat it
i don't think they run it into the
ground and then you're like stop saying
it's just something that he heard
he's like j-rock with you know what i'm
saying
it's too much too many papa's like once
or twice
is it right are you kidding me first of
all my piece is hanging
low into the left dude they're just
showing their dicks on [ __ ] youtube
i'm sorry fighter and the kid fans
because i'm gonna clip this
why are you what you're gonna defend
this one
why are you this is normal not only is
this normal not only do they think this
segment was so good they clipped it
oh this is this is a clip segment this
is good stuff
what do we do you think my legs are my
legs are [ __ ]
stupid dude they're stupid my legs are
better than his
excuse me that is i hate saying it
it hurts my feelings i'm bummed out
i'm sorry i know you're upset i don't
blame you i'm upset he played the same
position
there's some [ __ ] going on with you
right now and i get it and i've never
seen you like this
i was like [ __ ] back in college i know
you were but you're
tied in you're in high school well you
played tea didn't you play tea
weren't you going to try to be drafted
in the nfl at ta they made me
i was a fullback h-back dude but then
they made you a tight end nope you can
catch the choice
okay i don't catch popping okay i don't
i don't know the bottom line
what's he weigh
but it's unfortunate because he should
be working in hvac
[Laughter]
you're right you should be in someone's
attic right now
replacing an air handler knocking tin
yeah he's a he's tall
[Laughter]
just run it into the [ __ ] ground dude
what was college i feel like he was
taller than that but
no he's definitely six six yeah okay he
played at ohio state that's oh you know
what i've seen that man play ball and
he's a hell of a player yeah
hell of a player
shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut the [ __ ] up shut up
how many times is he gonna say it royce
papa
want to see my legs bro dude if somebody
in your family said it that much i'd be
like could he stop
can you stop saying papa yeah well so
big and weirdly strong like so big i was
like well yeah i mean you obviously are
doing that
all the time because we're around other
comedians right i'm
a ginormous man yeah for an nfl player
you're kind of regular
well you're big but you're not normal
first off don't call yourself a comedian
i mean that's an insult let's start with
that all right
and the only thing [ __ ] gigantic
about you are the dead spots in your
brain you cte riddled [ __ ] and your ego
and your honoring sense of self
of accomplishment papa that that one
really is bugging me no i'm not normal
yeah well i'm not normal i'm small well
for ufc heavyweight i'm
sure you are yeah dude like those guys
are huge
yeah yeah he's a star now now you might
be you might be as strong as he is
you're very strong right he's a [ __ ]
i remember playing in college he's a
stud yes girls are dying these girls i
hate guys
you're you're a bro jack studs
you know what he likes doing he likes to
jack some stunts
just jacking them just jack those studs
until they get a release
it's so [ __ ] hey mike are you wearing
your tighty whities today
yes yeah see your legs yeah you'll see
my legs
your legs bro wrong with these people
were you and without being uh without
breakfast
right cat is that he is hot he's your
hands i'll get all right
maybe maybe we ask the fans
would you say that would you say because
i've heard from lauren lando you're
you're
you're as strong as most nfl players
when you're training does it say does
give me his combine numbers what are you
doing two combine numbers yeah
go type in nick uh yeah we know how to
search for combine numbers you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
dude he played ohio state he's not just
basically he must have been so good yeah
he's such a stunt
yeah uh would you type in combine
literally you'd see it you could see
what he typed in
can you not read um look what i'm
talking about somebody in the chat
actually said how does a conversation
about a washed up tight end lead to two
grown men taking their pants off
seriously
numbers all right scroll down well
active player in the nfl
i mean you can scroll down how about
here comment sends
yeah yeah give me that [ __ ]
um
so i ran a four five eight that was
faster vertical twenty nine
i jumped higher four eight nine five
four i is that true
yep you don't have to do the fake cough
thing we know you were better than
everybody
that's why this guy was in the nfl and
you're literally not
okay here's the thing stop the fake
coffee
sorry sorry i'm not gonna get mad i
brought this video up i shouldn't be
this man hey you're the one
brought it he's way better at football
what did you run what did you run a 40
in
no that was his sat scores of 40. 40.
and you get [ __ ] 100 points for
getting your name right
he got always he didn't get his last
name right
not even the full first name i like the
slow turn
four six that's very quick for a man
your size
i i don't i tell dick jokes and it
doesn't help but first off
i wouldn't call them jokes personally
all you do is talk about dicks
talking about dicks isn't dick jokes
papa papa
papa [ __ ] papa shango over here
four six is no joke oh lord lando right
now well we're on four six eight brian
lauren lando said they're strong and
then there's brendan shop and he's the
strength coaster
he's a strength he said he said that you
carried a hundred pounds in each hand
for like
five minutes or something and beat all
the linemen
right right kind of how all the
comedians in the joe rogan universe have
to carry
carry you on their back like a [ __ ]
hundred pound waste
[ __ ] you're the dead weight brendan
you're [ __ ]
okay it's not a big deal i'll bring him
in everything on his pro day but here's
the here's the what is
this what is with this need to be better
than everybody else's stuff when
he's not better than anyone at home uh
he's better at having
legs you're strong here's the thing he's
a really really good football player
he's i know who he is he's phenomenal
football dude he's so much better sure
okay all right
all right when combat you have to have
strong calves
all right cross velvet shirt wasn't
feeling it but maybe he's feeling now in
a in a tusk
in a tusk up in a tussle up you're
talking about a
you guys get he gets in and goes hey bro
you know i saw you looking at my girl
yeah
don't look at my girl and gives you a
shove around sure gives you a shovel
brandon wasn't looking at your girl he
had a thousand-yard stare because all
the
neurons are not firing correctly in his
brain he's just like
are you staring at my girl what where am
is the fight over i didn't tap did i
yeah you did
for sure yeah what about it damn fingers
are the jackals
i tell dick jokes look at my dick
you're talking about in the comments
store that closed back door bar you take
them into deep water
well not that deep of water somebody to
the chest is these guys must be high
dude mike and i have been retardedly
high and we've never compared legs
but he might be no no papa it's me the
shallow end oh really to me the shallow
one but he might be the girl in jaws and
you pull him under what happens he
doesn't know what's going on yet doesn't
he
uh-huh yeah that's brendan's favorite
movie joel's by the way i'm noticing
something here
um so they film the show probably in the
daytime
yeah probably towards the morning i
think so brandon's coming in with a nice
little cup of coffee
but brian's having a little sip he's
having an adult beverage
at what time it doesn't matter because
he doesn't have a wife anymore to tell
him not to
good bump just wondering if maybe those
things are connected that's all i
don't know we'll never know i don't know
i'll never know but i'm just curious why
a man would be drinking so early in the
day i mean i don't even do that
brendan's having a [ __ ] brian's
having a drink papa
just pounding that liquor yeah don't
bring it out dude that's a line
it's funny calen's jeans are so tight
that he has to take his wallet out and
put it on the table
oh my god i know it's a little thing i
know but that is embarrassing
but it's i've never i never understood
the tight jean thing
because i'm like i want pockets i want
room i i never
i understood baggy pants jinko's not
that crazy but just baggy and generally
not a pair of jenkins just
of course when i was a kid but i'm
talking about in adult years i still
enjoy baggy pet week you can put [ __ ] in
your pocket
like royce just said you gotta go i
gotta take all of my belongings out and
sit down
daintily so i don't tear the crotch in
my tiny pants
now people are asking who has better
legs in the chat one for royce and two
for merch
mike we're gonna have to do it no it's
fine just voice there you go
okay i'm not gonna be i won there you go
so i take my wallet out and my phone now
you see how not it was
sure cool you have better legs anyway
moving on
that's how every guy should have that
conversation bro [ __ ] i got way
better legs than you
okay i guess cool can we go back to
doing what we were doing now not being
language you catch balls
you're tough guy big athlete phenomenal
he's a phenomenal
player not but now and he looks dope
there oh my look he looks
dope there he's he looks dope there
somebody pointed this out in the
comments last time we talked about him
but he goes
brendan calls the stuff that people wear
instead of like if i give you my mic
that's a nice shirt i'll be like hey
cool man i like your shirt
he calls them outfits he does say alfred
have heard that outfits i've heard that
word confused
nice outfit that's fair here's the thing
you take a great white out of the water
now he's got some problems he can flap
he can flop around
right like if you take [ __ ] brennan
out of the ufc he's flopping around and
but the difference is you don't give a
great white a showtime special
you let it [ __ ] die on the dock i
would rather watch a great white
showtime special
papa's good on lan nc here's the oh
[ __ ] dude i'd rather be the great white
concert
hey brown and hey surfing turf
you're surfing turf i'm surfing you're
surfing you're surfing
turf what are they even talking about
bro
i i would i want to even make a joke but
i really don't know what they're talking
about
anymore different term yeah surfing in
turf
yeah so you're not hearing him
beep out of him surf and turf what do
you want water land bro so you're not
hearing a
beep out of him but then he goes
hey papa failed nfl player
so is he saying the papa thing now i
don't
know what's going on royce i don't
know but you played no game hurt your
feelings
no it doesn't at all your nostrils you
get a little vein in your neck no not at
all
okay hahaha like blood is still getting
to his brain nice try brian callan
i ain't falling for it i'm calling
[ __ ] that's all necrosis yeah that's
not nothing getting up there get the
mythbusters guys on top of this yeah
seriously he's [ __ ] brendan brennan
shop is just a brain step with a stan
brain stem with a stand-up career
i know what you know he's such an
amazing athlete yeah we're not even
comparable it's okay he was starting
tight in for
ohio state the biggest football
university on the planet
it's not the biggest football university
on the planet i mean it's big ohio state
has a very big
one pretty big one but not the biggest
not the biggest and also my favorite
college outside university of colorado
and clemson have
one of the biggest sometimes it's not
that texas like the longhorn
that's you tennessee that's another
really big
football university i mean you play
university of florida man university of
florida that's a
huge football school too ohio is number
one though yeah
ohio state i mean ohio state's doing me
wrong guys i'm telling you number one
alabama
alabama alabama that's a [ __ ]
big [ __ ] number one though papa
michigan there's another one i mean papa
you're wrong
bro stop you stop so i don't want to hit
you but i don't hate you i don't want to
be them
here's the thing papa nick thank you
from your boy here fashion guy like you
did i'm a fashion guy like you so he's
going to talk they're going to comment
about
about this football player's romper
tight is out tight
show out tight jeans are so i didn't
mind his jeans i was in fact
noticing them look at him there you have
jeans like that brennan i've seen you
wear them i've seen you wear these jeans
imagine being a man in your 30s and
being like tight jeans are out
he looks like he looks like a hold on he
looks like a thicker aaron rodgers right
there he looks good there he looks he's
good there anthem
this is hold on no but he looks right
there he
he looks handsome right there look at
the dying piece standing next to him
and that's what they're going to talk
about no see look look how his wife is
objectively
beautiful gorgeous wife say what you
want his wife is
[ __ ] a 12. but look at he's like a
thicker aaron rodgers though royce
they're noticing him
yeah hmm thicker aaron rodgers
he's a handsome ass girl is a [ __ ]
dot that died
she's a 10 she's a 10. 12. but you know
sound like they just kind of blow past
that yeah she's a thing yeah she's all
right but
let's talk about somebody some more you
don't catch footballs for the buck guys
and not get your dicks up well there he
is i know he's the alpha male that's
fine he's the he's the apex alpha
look at his legs i'm sorry i hate this
conversation no it's a bummer for me hey
he's got
hammies that make yours look like your
legs look like you have wickets hey is
it friday at red lobster
dudes surfing turf
yeah i'm not doing it either anyone
no no no no
no no who watches this [ __ ] who
watches this [ __ ]
you people need to be quarantined if you
watch this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] hell man
you brought this clip so i know man but
shit's on you i know i get it
i get it but i mean come on
when combat
i know that i know that but you tend to
look like he's got a big nipple
you tend to look here's
what brandon said you tend to look
here's the thing
all right let's talk talk to nipper oh
they've been together for a while but
i'll suck those now listen i will suck
his nipples make me horny and i'm a
straight guy i will suck the [ __ ] out of
his dick is that what he said
did i hear it incorrectly that's exactly
what he said
papa this is beyond get and i know
they're going to use the whole
dude can you imagine if they were joking
yes hold on you got it nick you got a
tip
is there any other sl uh shirtless pigs
maybe
his life what the [ __ ] man
this is so uncomfortable man hey man hey
mike
any more shirtless pics any more
shirtless pics of this guy
likes make your legs look a little bit
crystally as you're doing this
i i'm sorry i [ __ ] i'm embarrassed
hey trust me no one's more embarrassed
than us yeah
we're embarrassed for you this girl up
there in that low cut though i'll go
that one go that one
well she's she's fantastic it's
fantastic
their kids are gonna be deliciously
beautiful whoa
that's not the adjective you use to
describe a child am i wrong
i don't know if i would call a kid
delicious bro your kids are going to be
so
[ __ ] deliciously sexy
does someone say that about what are
your kids bro you two are going to have
the most
kids i've ever seen about my kids
[Laughter]
delicious kids that's really weird right
i mean deliciously is terrible thing to
say but i mean beautiful chocolate
that was a good that was at least he
covered it nice save brian [ __ ] i can't
believe i said hey you want to have a
seat
chris hanson style you want to hey we
know we got the rest hey you want to
have a seat chris hansen i used to say
that like chris hanson
have a seat remember chris hanson wants
some lemonade for datelines
some cookies remember to catch a
practice have a seat have a seat like
chris hanson like
chris hanson sit down over here chris
hanson
hey stupid since you're a big heavy
hitter in comedy let me explain
[ __ ] let me explain it to your [ __ ]
legioned brain
um legion brain you [ __ ] don't have
if you have to explain the reference
it's not a funny joke oh [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
look we're done we're done with this
we're done with this
bro tony bro look at these two they're
gonna have the most full kids that
you've ever seen i mean i swear to god
delicious scene i want to
click that's why brian all right mike
it's like what are you doing